selamat kembali ke Memahami Maklumat dan Pengiraan Kuantum nama saya John Watrous dan saya ialah pengarah teknikal untuk pendidikan di IBM
Quantum ini ialah pelajaran ke-12 dalam siri ini dan merupakan pelajaran terakhir dalam unit ketiga yang berkaitan dengan formulasi umum
maklumat kuantum pelajaran ini berpusat pada konsep asas dalam maklumat Kuantum iaitu
penulenan Keadaan Kuantum penulenan Keadaan Kuantum yang diwakili oleh sesetengah matriks ketumpatan ialah
keadaan tulen bagi sistem kompaun yang lebih besar yang meninggalkan kita dengan keadaan asal apabila baki sistem kompaun itu
dibuang atau disisih setiap matriks ketumpatan mempunyai penulenan dan kita boleh belajar banyak
tentang Keadaan Kuantum dan maklumat Kuantum secara umum dengan mengkaji penulenan pada peringkat intuitif
vektor Keadaan Kuantum yang mewakili keadaan tulen adalah objek matematik yang lebih mudah berbanding matriks ketumpatan dan dengan memikirkan tentang
penulenan bagi keadaan-keadaan kita dapat melihat keadaan kuantum sewenang-wenangnya bagi sistem sebagai hanya bahagian daripada sesuatu yang lebih besar tapi
lebih mudah kita juga akan bincangkan Kesetiaan antara dua Keadaan Kuantum yang merupakan nilai yang mengukur
kesamaan atau pertindihan antara keduanya dan ia kerap digunakan sebagai cara mengukur sebaik mana keadaan tertentu berbanding
sesetengah keadaan ideal khususnya kita akan bincangkan takrifan kesetiaan berserta beberapa sifat asasnya dan kita akan lihat
bagaimana Kesetiaan berkait dengan penulenan ini adalah gambaran keseluruhan pelajaran kita akan mulakan dengan penulenan termasuk
takrifan dan bukti mudah kewujudannya yang memberitahu kita cara mencari satu jika kita memerlukannya kemudian kita akan bincangkan sesuatu yang dikenali
sebagai penguraian Schmidt bagi vektor Keadaan Kuantum dua sistem dan kita akan lihat bagaimana penguraian Schmidt berkait dengan
penulenan kemudian kita akan bincangkan hubungan yang sangat penting antara mana-mana dua penulenan bagi keadaan yang sama yang dikenali sebagai
kesetaraan unitari bagi penulenan dan akhirnya kita akan melalui beberapa contoh kemudian kita beralih kepada Kesetiaan
termasuk takrifannya dan beberapa sifat asasnya kita akan bincangkan Lema Pengukuran Lembut yang merupakan fakta yang sangat
berguna yang menghubungkan Kesetiaan kembali kepada pengukuran dan akhirnya untuk mengakhiri pelajaran kita akan beralih kepada teorem Uhlmann yang
mewujudkan hubungan asas antara Kesetiaan dan penulenan jom kita mulakan dengan
takrifan penulenan penulenan bagi keadaan yang kita andaikan diwakili oleh matriks ketumpatan
ialah keadaan tulen bagi sistem kompaun yang lebih besar yang meninggalkan keadaan asal yang kita mulakan dengannya apabila baki
sistem kompaun disisih kita boleh nyatakan ini dengan lebih tepat dalam istilah matematik seperti
berikut jika kita ada sistem X yang berada dalam keadaan rho yang bermaksud rho ialah matriks ketumpatan yang mewakili keadaan X
dan s ialah vektor Keadaan Kuantum sepasang sistem XY sedemikian rupa sehingga mengesan keluar y dari keadaan tulen ket psi bra psi
meninggalkan kita dengan rho maka kita katakan s ialah penulenan bagi rho sudah tentu nama-nama tidak penting kita
boleh namakan sistem dan keadaan kita apa sahaja yang kita mahu dan susunan sistem juga tidak penting misalnya
jika sistem y berada di sebelah kiri berbanding di sebelah kanan tapi semua yang lain sama kita masih merujuk psi sebagai penulenan bagi rho tapi kita akan
teruskan dengan persediaan ini untuk baki pelajaran demi kesederhanaan dan perkara pertama yang perlu dikatakan
tentang takrifan ialah penulenan sentiasa wujud untuk setiap matriks ketumpatan rho dan untuk lebih tepat setiap matriks ketumpatan
rho mempunyai penulenan seperti yang diterangkan dalam takrifan dengan syarat sistem y sekurang-kurangnya sebesar X yang
bermaksud y mempunyai sekurang-kurangnya sebanyak keadaan klasik seperti X konsep penulenan dan
fakta bahawa penulenan sentiasa wujud rupanya sangat penting dan ia juga sebahagian daripada apa yang menjadikan maklumat Kuantum cantik dan mudah-mudahan saya akan
dapat meyakinkan anda tentang fakta itu menjelang akhir pelajaran sekarang jom kita buktikan bahawa setiap matriks ketumpatan mempunyai penulenan dan dalam
prosesnya kita akan lihat bagaimana kita boleh dapatkan penulenan apabila kita memerlukannya sama seperti yang kita ada dalam takrifan
penulenan katakan X ialah sistem dan rho ialah matriks ketumpatan yang mewakili keadaan
X sekarang pertimbangkan sebarang ungkapan rho sebagai gabungan cembung keadaan tulen seperti yang kita tulis di skrin dalam kata-kata
untuk sesetengah pilihan integer positif n kita ada vektor kebarangkalian p 0 hingga PN tolak satu serta vektor
Keadaan Kuantum fi 0 hingga fi n tolak satu dan dengan merata-ratakan keadaan tulen yang sepadan yang diwajari oleh kebarangkalian kita
dapat rho misalnya kita boleh gunakan teorem spektral untuk mendapat ungkapan rho seperti ini dan jika kita buat begitu kita
boleh ambil n sebagai bilangan keadaan klasik X sebenarnya kita boleh ambil n sebagai pangkat rho yang
sama dengan bilangan nilai-nilai eigen bukan sifar bagi rho dengan mengira masing-masing bilangan kali yang sama dengan multiplasitinya dan
itu tidak pernah lebih besar daripada bilangan keadaan klasik X tapi ia boleh lebih kecil sebaliknya ini tidak
mesti penguraian spektral bagi rho dan kita tidak perlukan vektor Keadaan Kuantum ini untuk ortonormal misalnya sebarang ungkapan rho seperti ini
adalah baik dan ini adalah penulenan rho julat jumlah merentangi nilai yang sama seperti
dalam ungkapan rho kita dan di dalam jumlah kita ambil punca kuasa dua kebarangkalian didarab dengan fi A ditensor
dengan ket a di sini ngomong-ngomong kita mengandaikan bahawa 0 hingga n tolak satu adalah keadaan klasik sistem kedua y jadi ia
masuk akal bahawa s ialah vektor Keadaan Kuantum pasangan XY seperti dalam takrifan ia sebenarnya tidak penting
di sini bahawa kita menggunakan keadaan asas piawai Y dalam ungkapan ini anda boleh gantikan sebarang koleksi ortonormal
keadaan sebagai ganti ket 0 hingga ket n tolak satu jika anda mahu dan sekarang kita boleh semak bahawa ini memang
penulenan dengan mengira Surih Separa ke atas y ini adalah ungkapan keadaan yang kita dapat dengan menjalankan surih separa
surih ket a bra b ialah sama ada satu atau sifar bergantung pada sama ada a sama dengan b atau tidak dan jadi ungkapan
itu memudah kepada ungkapan asal kita bagi rho dan semudah itulah jadi sangat mudah untuk dapatkan
penulenan selagi kita ada cukup keadaan klasik Y atau secara alternatif set ortonormal yang cukup besar untuk digunakan
sebagai ganti keadaan asas piawai ket 0 hingga ket n tolak satu dan ngomong-ngomong jika bilangan
keadaan klasik Y lebih kecil daripada pangkat rho maka tidak akan ada penulenan dan saya serahkan itu kepada anda
untuk renungkan jika anda mahu ini adalah contoh jom kita pertimbangkan
matriks ketumpatan yang kita lihat beberapa kali dalam pelajaran tentang matriks ketumpatan di sini kita ada ungkapan matriks ketumpatan ini
sebagai gabungan cembung keadaan tulen ia bukan penguraian spektral tapi kita tidak
kisah dan dengan hampir tanpa usaha langsung kita boleh tulis penulenan bagi keadaan dengan mengikut
resipi itu bukan satu-satunya penulenan matriks ketumpatan ini penulenan tidak unik tapi tidak apa
WEBVTT
takrifan itu tidak menyatakan apa-apa tentang keunikan dan sebenarnya ada hubungan yang sangat menarik di antara penulenan berbeza bagi keadaan yang sama tapi
kita akan bincangkan itu sedikit kemudian dalam pelajaran seterusnya kita akan pertimbangkan penguraian Schmidt yang merupakan ungkapan
vektor Keadaan Kuantum bipartit dalam bentuk tertentu yang akan saya huraikan sebentar lagi namanya sempena Erhard
Schmidt Schmidt yang sama yang dikenali dengan prosedur ortonormalisasi Gram-Schmidt tapi dalam kes penguraian Schmidt ia mungkin tidak patut
dinamakan sempena Schmidt ia sebenarnya setara secara matematik dengan sesuatu yang dipanggil penguraian nilai singular untuk matriks yang merupakan sesuatu yang
sebenarnya ditemui semula beberapa kali tapi itu memang berlaku kadang-kadang tapi bagaimanapun inilah yang kita maksudkan
apabila kita merujuk kepada penguraian Schmidt untuk sebarang pilihan vektor Keadaan Kuantum s untuk sepasang
sistem XY sentiasa mungkin untuk menulis s dalam bentuk khas bentuk itu seperti yang
kita ada di skrin di mana r ialah sesetengah integer positif p 0 hingga p r tolak satu adalah nombor nyata positif yang
bersama-sama membentuk vektor kebarangkalian x0 hingga XR tolak satu adalah vektor unit yang sepadan dengan sistem X dan y0
hingga yr tolak satu adalah vektor unit yang sepadan dengan sistem y kini itu mungkin tidak kelihatan
khas sehingga saya memberitahu anda bahawa kedua-dua set x0 hingga XR tolak satu dan y0 hingga yr tolak satu mestilah
ortonormal jadi kenapa itu khas baik jika kita pilih sebarang asas untuk salah satu daripada dua asas katakan sahaja
vektor-vektor X yang sepadan dengan sistem X maka kita sentiasa boleh nyatakan s dalam bentuk ini dan itu akan memaksa kita untuk
memilih vektor-vektor Y dengan cara tertentu sebenarnya kita buat ini agak rutin seperti yang kita lakukan dengan asas piawai apabila kita
menetapkan diri untuk menganalisis pengukuran asas piawai tapi secara umumnya walaupun kita pilih asas ortonormal untuk vektor-vektor X
vektor-vektor Y yang kita dapat tidak semestinya ortonormal begitu juga jika anda pilih
asas ortonormal untuk vektor-vektor Y dan anda cuba nyatakan s dalam bentuk sekali lagi anda boleh tapi sekali lagi vektor-vektor X tidak akan
semestinya ortonormal dan akhirnya jika anda memilih vektor-vektor ortonormal untuk kedua-dua sistem dan
anda cuba nyatakan s dalam bentuk seperti ini ia tidak semestinya berhasil kerana anda mungkin mendapati diri memerlukan beberapa sebutan silang tapi hanya ada satu
indeks dalam jumlah ini iaitu a jadi bentuk itu khas tapi ia sentiasa mungkin untuk
menulis vektor unit s yang diberikan seperti ini dan inilah cara anda boleh melakukannya pertama kira penguraian spektral
untuk keadaan terkurang salah satu daripada dua sistem tidak penting yang mana tapi demi menerangkan cara ini dilakukan jom kita lihat keadaan terkurang
X jadi kita mengesan keluar y jadi itu bermaksud p 0 hingga p r tolak satu adalah nilai-nilai
eigen bagi keadaan terkurang rho ini dan x0 hingga XR tolak satu adalah vektor-vektor eigen unit yang sepadan dengan nilai-nilai eigen ini dan
ngomong-ngomong pemahaman di sini ialah kita mengabaikan sebutan untuk nilai-nilai eigen yang sifar kerana sebutan itu tidak menyumbang apa-apa kepada
jumlah dan itu bermaksud p 0 hingga p r tolak satu semuanya nombor nyata positif dan r ialah bilangan nilai-nilai eigen bukan sifar
dengan mengira multiplasitinya yang sama dengan pangkat rho jadi itu memberi kita p 0 hingga p r
tolak satu serta x0 hingga XR tolak satu dan yang tinggal hanyalah mencari vektor-vektor y0 hingga yr
tolak satu hanya ada satu pilihan yang boleh berhasil vektor-vektor itu ditentukan secara unik pada titik ini dan ia boleh
dengan mudah dicari menggunakan formula mudah yang ditunjukkan di skrin dan yang menakjubkan di sini ialah
jika kita takrifkan vektor-vektor ini dengan cara ini maka ia dijamin ortonormal dan itu memberi kita penguraian Schmidt saya tidak akan hujahkan itu dalam
video ini tapi ia tidak terlalu sukar dan anda boleh rujuk bahan bertulis untuk pelajaran sekiranya anda berminat semak
huraian video untuk pautan seperti biasa sebagai contoh jom kita pertimbangkan
vektor Keadaan Kuantum ini yang kita peroleh sebagai penulenan bagi contoh matriks ketumpatan yang kita terus kembali
kepada ia bukan penguraian Schmidt kerana keadaan sifar dan plus tidak ortonormal tapi kita boleh cari satu
menggunakan prosedur yang baru saya huraikan langkah pertama ialah mengira penguraian spektral untuk keadaan terkurang
X iaitu contoh matriks ketumpatan yang sama itu dan ini adalah penguraian spektral I daripadanya yang kita lihat
dalam pelajaran 9 jadi kita pilih p 0 P1 x0 dan X1 seperti yang
ditunjukkan di skrin p 0 dan P1 adalah nilai-nilai eigen bagi rho dan x0 dan X1 adalah
vektor-vektor eigen unit yang sepadan dan jadi yang tinggal ialah mengira y0 dan y1 dan jika kita buat ini kita dapat ket Plus
untuk y0 dan -1 darab ket tolak untuk y1 itu tidak serta-merta anda perlu
sebenarnya buat pengiraan untuk melihatnya tapi itulah yang kita dapat dan seperti yang dijangkakan kedua-dua vektor itu ortonormal seperti
yang akan selalu berlaku jika anda telah buat pengiraan dengan betul dan itu memberi kita penguraian
Schmidt penguraian Schmidt sangat berguna dalam banyak situasi dan tidak lama lagi kita akan lihat apa yang ia beritahu kita
tentang penulenan penulenan tidak unik Keadaan Kuantum tertentu yang diwakili
oleh matriks ketumpatan sebenarnya mempunyai banyak penulenan yang tidak terhingga walau bagaimanapun ada hubungan yang rapat
yang sentiasa berlaku antara mana-mana dua penulenan bagi keadaan yang sama dan ia kadang-kadang dipanggil
kesetaraan unitari bagi penulenan inilah cara ia berfungsi biarkan rho menjadi matriks ketumpatan
yang mewakili Keadaan Kuantum sistem X dan katakan kita ada mana-mana dua penulenan bagi keadaan itu yang merupakan
keadaan tulen sistem kompaun yang sama jadi demi ketepatan katakan s dan fi
adalah vektor Keadaan Kuantum sepasang sistem XY yang kedua-duanya memberi kita rho apabila sistem Y disisih
apa yang dikatakan kesetaraan unitari bagi penulenan ialah mesti ada operasi unitari U yang bertindak hanya ke atas
sistem y yang mengubah psi menjadi fi dalam erti kata lain walaupun ini adalah
penulenan sewenang-wenangnya bagi rho dan kita tidak andaikan apa-apa tentangnya kecuali bahawa kedua-duanya menulekan rho dan ia
kedua-duanya keadaan sistem kompaun XY yang sama ia mesti setara dalam suatu makna sehingga operasi unitari pada y
sahaja kita akan lihat beberapa contoh yang menggambarkan kenapa ini menarik dan apa implikasinya tapi pertama jom kita
lihat kenapa ia benar jom mulakan dengan penguraian spektral bagi rho yang merupakan
matriks ketumpatan yang kedua-dua psi dan fi tulenkan dan sama seperti yang kita buat semasa kita bincangkan penguraian Schmidt kita
akan anggap kita telah buang semua sebutan yang sepadan dengan nilai-nilai eigen sifar jadi p 0 hingga p r tolak satu
semuanya nombor nyata positif x0 hingga XR tolak satu adalah vektor-vektor eigen ortonormal bagi rho dan r kebetulan ialah
WEBVTT
pangkat rho dan ngomong-ngomong sekadar catatan sampingan perhatikan betapa kerap kita mencapai teorem spektral pada ketika ini
ia alat yang sangat berguna dan sebenarnya kita akan hilang tanpanya pun bagaimanapun sekarang kita ada penguraian spektral
rho kita boleh kira penguraian Schmidt bagi dua vektor kita sama seperti sebelumnya dan ia akan
hampir serupa sepenuhnya pekali-pekali dan vektor-vektor X adalah sama kerana ia datang dari penguraian spektral keadaan terkurang yang
sama untuk kedua-dua vektor satu-satunya perbezaan ialah kita mungkin mendapat vektor-vektor berbeza untuk sistem kedua untuk
vektor pertama iaitu s kita akan mendapat satu set vektor y0 hingga yr tolak satu dan untuk vektor kedua iaitu f kita akan
mendapat koleksi yang mungkin berbeza yang boleh kita panggil z0 hingga zr tolak satu jadi kini kita ada penguraian Schmidt
bagi dua vektor kita yang kelihatan sangat serupa kecuali bahawa vektor-vektor untuk sistem kedua mungkin berbeza tapi ini
adalah penguraian Schmidt jadi kedua-dua koleksi ini adalah ortonormal dan jadi kita boleh cukup pilih
matriks unitari U yang menghantar ya ke za untuk setiap a anda sentiasa boleh buat itu operasi unitari
sebenarnya setara dengan peta linear yang mengubah satu asas ortonormal kepada yang lain dan jika
kedua-dua set ini tidak merentangi keseluruhan ruang yang sepadan dengan Y kita sentiasa boleh perluaskan kedua-duanya kepada asas-asas ortonormal
menggunakan prosedur ortonormalisasi Gram-Schmidt yang kebetulan dan itulah cara kesetaraan unitari
bagi penulenan dibuktikan dalam pelajaran empat siri ini kita bincangkan protokol pengekodan superpadat
yang membolehkan penghantar menghantar dua bit klasik kepada penerima dengan menghantar satu qubit dengan kos satu ebit
keterikatan bersama jadi saya mengandaikan anda sudah biasa dengan protokol itu dan tujuan contoh ini ialah untuk secara ringkas
jelaskan bagaimana ia berkait dengan kesetaraan unitari bagi penulenan ingat bahawa cara
protokol itu berfungsi ialah Alice dan Bob berkongsi ebit atau dalam erti kata lain Keadaan Bell fi plus Alice memilih untuk mengubah
Keadaan Bell itu kepada mana-mana daripada Empat Keadaan Bell bergantung pada dua bit yang dia ingin hantar kemudian dia hantar
qubitnya kepada Bob dan dia mengukur untuk melihat Keadaan Bell mana yang ada perhatikan bahawa keempat-empat Keadaan Bell
memberi kita keadaan terkurang yang sama untuk qubit Bob iaitu keadaan bercampur sepenuhnya dan sebenarnya itu sudah cukup
untuk menyimpulkan bahawa pengekodan superpadat mungkin dilakukan keempat-empat Keadaan Bell menulenkan keadaan bercampur sepenuhnya jadi melalui
kesetaraan unitari bagi penulenan kita tahu bahawa mesti mungkin bagi Alice untuk mengubah Keadaan Bell fi plus kepada
yang lain dengan menggunakan sesetengah operasi unitari pada qubitnya tentunya tidak sukar untuk hasilkan operasi unitari yang
sebenarnya berfungsi dan ia sangat mudah tapi menarik juga bahawa kita boleh sampai kepada kesimpulan bahawa ini adalah
mungkin tanpa memikirkan operasi unitari itu sendiri dan lebih-lebih lagi kita boleh simpulkan
bahawa generalisasi pengekodan superpadat kepada sistem yang lebih besar adalah mungkin dengan syarat kita mempunyai sesetengah cara untuk menggeneralisasikan Keadaan Bell kepada sistem yang lebih besar
supaya semuanya memberi keadaan bercampur sepenuhnya sebagai keadaan terkurang Bob dan sebenarnya ada beberapa cara yang diketahui untuk melakukan
itu tetapan berbeza yang mana kesetaraan unitari bagi penulenan mempunyai implikasi ialah kriptografi
kuantum dan salah satu implikasi paling pentingnya ialah ia menolak kewujudan protokol Kuantum yang selamat tanpa syarat untuk
primitif kriptografi yang dikenali sebagai komitmen bit jadi apakah komitmen bit komitmen bit ialah contoh
primitif kriptografi yang bermaksud tugas atau prosedur peringkat rendah yang menyediakan beberapa fungsi asas yang
kemudian boleh digunakan sebagai blok bangunan untuk melakukan perkara yang lebih menarik seperti mencipta skim tandatangan digital atau membina
protokol pengetahuan sifar misalnya dalam kes komitmen bit fungsi asasnya ialah satu
pemain Alice dapat komit kepada nilai binari pilihannya kepada pemain kedua Bob tapi pilihannya kekal tersembunyi
sehingga dia memilih untuk mendedahkannya kita memerlukan dua sifat khusus daripada protokol yang melaksanakan komitmen bit
ia mesti mengikat yang bermaksud Alice tidak boleh bertukar fikiran setelah dia komit kepada bit dan ia
mesti menyembunyikan yang bermaksud Bob tidak boleh tentukan bit Alice sehingga dia memilih untuk mendedahkan
itu jadi adalah agak bagus untuk dapat melaksanakan primitif ini menggunakan maklumat Kuantum kerana ia adalah
primitif yang berguna tapi tanpa sebarang andaian tambahan rupanya tidak mungkin untuk melakukannya dengan sempurna dengan maklumat Kuantum atau bahkan hampir
sempurna dan kesetaraan unitari bagi penulenan mendedahkan bahawa idea itu pada peringkat yang sangat tinggi ialah
jika ada protokol Kuantum untuk komitmen bit maka mesti ada apa yang dipanggil versi tulenan protokol itu di mana kita boleh bayangkan
Alice mempunyai sistem a Bob mempunyai sistem B dan selepas komitmen dibuat tapi sebelum Alice mendedahkan pasangan AB berada dalam
salah satu daripada dua keadaan tulen psi sifar atau psi satu bergantung pada bit yang Alice
komit jika protokol itu menyembunyikan sepenuhnya maka mesti bahawa Bob tidak dapat membezakan antara
dua komitmen jadi keadaan terkurangnya mesti sama untuk dua kemungkinan bagaimanapun itu bermakna melalui
kesetaraan unitari bagi penulenan bahawa Alice boleh mengubah salah satunya kepada yang lain dengan menggunakan sesetengah operasi unitari
kepada a sahaja jadi protokol itu sama sekali gagal untuk mengikat ada butiran di sana yang
saya tutup tapi inti perkara ialah kesetaraan unitari bagi penulenan memberitahu kita bahawa primitif ini bukan sesuatu
yang boleh kita laksanakan dengan boleh dipercayai menggunakan maklumat Kuantum tanpa andaian tambahan beberapa
jenis contoh terakhir implikasi kesetaraan unitari bagi penulenan ialah teorem yang dikenali sebagai
teorem Houston-Joseph-Wouters atau teorem hjw secara ringkasnya jom mulakan dengan pernyataan
teorem itu sendiri dan ini adalah versi yang sedikit dipermudahkan untuk mengelakkan beberapa teknikal supaya kita boleh tumpukan pada idea utama
katakan X dan Y adalah sistem dan F ialah sebarang vektor Keadaan Kuantum yang mewakili keadaan tulen pasangan
XY dan sekarang katakan kita fikirkan tentang keadaan terkurang sistem X sahaja dan kita hasilkan sebarang cara yang kita
pilih untuk nyatakan keadaan terkurang ini sebagai gabungan cembung keadaan tulen seperti yang ditunjukkan di skrin
misalnya bilangan N huruf besar dalam ungkapan ini yang merupakan bilangan keadaan tulen yang kita purata boleh
sewenang-wenangnya besar mungkin jauh lebih besar daripada dimensi ruang yang sepadan dengan X atau Y juga untuk
itu dan apa yang dikatakan teorem ialah mesti wujud pengukuran ke atas sistem y yang mempunyai n hasil sedemikian rupa sehingga
berikut berlaku apabila sistem Y diukur pertama setiap hasil pengukuran
muncul dengan kebarangkalian yang tepat sama dengan kebarangkalian yang sepadan dalam ungkapan kita tentang keadaan terkurang X sebagai
WEBVTT
gabungan cembung keadaan tulen dan kedua dengan syarat mendapat hasil pengukuran tertentu
keadaan X menjadi keadaan tulen yang sepadan daripada gabungan cembung jadi kenapa itu
menarik baik ia bermaksud bahawa untuk sebarang cara yang kita pilih untuk fikirkan tentang keadaan terkurang X sebagai gabungan cembung
keadaan tulen ada sesetengah pengukuran Y yang dengan berkesan menjadikan cara memikirkan tentang keadaan terkurang x ini
kenyataan dan yang mengagumkan ialah ini mungkin walaupun apabila keadaan f dipilih dahulu dan gabungan cembung
dipilih kemudian selagi ia adalah ungkapan keadaan terkurang X akan ada
pengukuran Y yang berfungsi tepat seperti ini jadi jom kita lihat bagaimana kita boleh buktikan
ini kita mulakan dengan dua ungkapan berbeza untuk keadaan terkurang X yang akan kita beri nama rho untuk
kemudahan seterusnya kita perkenalkan sistem Z baru yang keadaan klasiknya adalah kemungkinan hasil pengukuran atau
secara setara indeks dalam gabungan cembung kita dan sekarang kita boleh perhatikan bahawa dua vektor Keadaan Kuantum berikut
gamma 0 dan Gamma 1 yang merupakan kedua-duanya vektor keadaan bagi sistem kompaun XYZ adalah
kedua-duanya penulenan rho dan sekedar untuk jelaskan apabila kita memikirkan tentang vektor-vektor ini sebagai penulenan rho kita
memikirkan sistem Y dan Z bersama sebagai sistem kompaun tunggal yang disisih untuk meninggalkan
rho vektor pertama gamma 0 pada dasarnya sama dengan keadaan tulen asal fi kecuali kita
mulakan sistem Z baru kepada keadaan sifar adalah jelas bahawa jika kita sisih Y dan Z kita akan ditinggalkan dengan rho jadi gamma
0 adalah penulenan rho vektor kedua Gamma 1 pada dasarnya ialah vektor yang kita dapat dengan menulenkan
rho berdasarkan gabungan cembung sama seperti yang saya huraikan lebih awal dalam pelajaran kali ini sistem Y
dimulakan dan saya mengandaikan demi kesederhanaan bahawa sifar adalah keadaan klasik Y tapi anda boleh gantikan sebarang
keadaan asas piawai atau sebenarnya sebarang keadaan tulen Y ke dalam ungkapan ini dan ia tidak akan membuat sebarang perbezaan dalam mana-mana kes mengesan keluar Y dan
Z sekali lagi meninggalkan kita dengan rho jadi kesimpulannya ialah ini adalah kedua-duanya penulenan rho dan oleh itu melalui
kesetaraan unitari bagi penulenan ada operasi unitari U pada pasangan YZ yang mengubah gamma 0 kepada
Gamma 1 dan itulah sahaja yang kita perlukan untuk hasilkan penerangan pengukuran yang melakukan apa yang dikatakan teorem
cara mudah untuk menerangkannya ialah dengan rajah circuit seperti yang ditunjukkan di skrin dalam kata-kata kita mulakan dengan
keadaan fi kita perkenalkan Z yang dimulakan ke keadaan sifar jalankan U dan kemudian ukur sistem atas iaitu Z dengan
pengukuran asas piawai berkesan apa yang dilakukan ini ialah mengubah fi kepada Gamma Satu dan
hanya dengan melihat penerangan Gamma 1 kita dapat lihat bahawa ini melakukan apa yang dikatakan teorem iaitu kita mendapat
setiap hasil a dengan kebarangkalian PA dan dengan syarat mendapat a sistem X ditinggalkan dalam keadaan sa
dan sekedar untuk jelaskan pengukuran itu sendiri yang kewujudannya disiratkan oleh teorem dilaksanakan oleh
segala-galanya dalam segi empat putus-putus dalam rajah dan jika anda ingin tahu bagaimana
pengukuran boleh diterangkan sebagai koleksi matriks ini adalah ungkapannya saya tidak akan jelaskan bahagian ini dan ia
tidak benar-benar penting demi contoh tapi itu adalah ungkapan matriks pengukuran sekiranya anda
berminat seterusnya kita akan bincangkan Kesetiaan yang merupakan ukuran seberapa serupa dua Keadaan Kuantum atau secara alternatif seberapa banyak
pertindihan antara keduanya kita akan mulakan dengan takrifan yang mungkin kelihatan sedikit misteri pada
pandangan pertama tapi kita akan uraikannya dan menjelang akhir perbincangan saya harap saya akan meyakinkan anda bahawa ia adalah
sebenarnya fungsi yang jauh lebih bagus daripada yang mungkin kelihatan pada pandangan pertama dan inilah
takrifan itu Kesetiaan antara dua matriks ketumpatan rho dan sigma sama dengan surih punca kuasa dua
punca kuasa dua rho darab sigma darab punca kuasa dua rho kita akan bincangkan
pertama jom kita cuba buat makna daripada takrifan itu sendiri kita ada tiga punca kuasa dua dan
semuanya merujuk kepada punca kuasa dua matriks semi-definitif positif yang seperti yang kita bincangkan dalam pelajaran sebelumnya adalah
matriks semi-definitif positif yang unik yang dikuasaduakan untuk memberi kita matriks yang kita ambil punca kuasa duanya kerana
rho adalah matriks ketumpatan ia mesti semi-definitif positif jadi kita boleh ambil punca kuasa duanya dan jika kita fikirkan tentang punca kuasa dua rho darab
sigma darab punca kuasa dua rho sebentar kita nampak bahawa ia juga semi-definitif positif dan khususnya kita boleh tulis ia sebagai
M dagger darab M untuk M ialah punca kuasa dua sigma darab punca kuasa dua rho dan oleh itu kita boleh ambil punca kuasa dua
daripadanya khususnya kita boleh kira penguraian spektral bagi punca kuasa dua
rho darab sigma darab punca kuasa dua rho dan kemudian untuk ambil punca kuasa dua kita hanya perlu ambil punca kuasa dua nilai-nilai
eigen dan biarkan vektor-vektor eigen tidak berubah dan akhirnya kita ambil surih
matriks ini dan kerana surih sama dengan jumlah nilai-nilai eigen kita mendapat ungkapan yang ada di sini
jadi itu mungkin sesuatu yang anda tidak mahu kira secara tangan secara umumnya dan penjelasan ini mungkin tidak
menawarkan banyak pandangan tentang Kesetiaan atau kenapa kita mengambil berat tentangnya tapi mudah-mudahan ia menjelaskan
makna teknikal formula itu ngomong-ngomong sekadar catatan sampingan kadang-kadang orang takrifkan Kesetiaan sebagai
kuasa dua fungsi yang saya takrifkan di sini dan mereka merujuk fungsi ini sebagai Kesetiaan punca
anda akan lihat ia ditakrifkan dengan kedua-dua cara yang pastinya berpotensi menyebabkan kekeliruan tapi biasanya tidak
kerana orang pada umumnya cukup berhati-hati untuk menjelaskan takrifan mana yang mereka gunakan dan anda sepatutnya
pastikan untuk buat perkara yang sama pada pandangan saya sebenarnya tidak ada takrifan yang betul atau salah saya takrifkan ia
seperti ini hanya kerana saya terbiasa melakukannya dengan cara ini dan saya mendapati ia sedikit lebih mudah saya rasa kerana saya lebih suka mengkuasaduakan
sesuatu kemudian ambil punca kuasa dua kemudian apabila keperluan timbul tapi tentunya anda bebas untuk buat pilihan anda sendiri
tapi bagaimanapun biar saya kembali kepada Kesetiaan seperti yang ditakrifkan di sini ada cara setara lain untuk
takrifkan Kesetiaan dan ia sebenarnya fungsi yang cukup menakjubkan dalam aspek itu dan ia sebenarnya boleh dicirikan dalam beberapa cara yang cukup menarik
ini adalah cara yang cukup mudah untuk tulis semula takrifan dalam sebutan Norma surih yang kita lihat menjelang
akhir pelajaran sebelumnya saya tidak masuk terlalu banyak butiran tentang norma surih dan khususnya saya
tidak pun takrifkan ia untuk matriks bukan-Hermitian tapi ia mempunyai takrifan yang cukup mudah satu cara untuk takrifkan Norma surih bagi sebuah
WEBVTT
matriks sewenang-wenangnya m ialah ia ialah surih punca kuasa dua M darab M dagger atau secara setara surih punca kuasa dua
M dagger darab M anda mendapat nilai yang sama dengan cara mana pun anda melakukannya dan kita boleh gunakan takrifan itu untuk memudahkan
takrifan Kesetiaan seperti yang ada di bawah skrin dan itu bagus kerana ia mendedahkan bahawa
ia simetri dalam dua argumen kita juga boleh nyatakan Norma surih bagi matriks kuasa dua M sebagai
maksimum nilai mutlak surih M darab U yang merentangi semua matriks unitari U yang bukan jelas tapi ia
memang benar dan itu memberi kita ungkapan lain untuk Kesetiaan jadi di sini kita ada tiga
takrifan setara untuk Kesetiaan dan itu baru permulaan ada beberapa takrifan setara lain dan
kita akan lihat satu yang sangat penting yang datang dari teorem Uhlmann menjelang akhir pelajaran
okey jadi itu bagus tapi apakah maksudnya semua pada peringkat intuitif dan kenapa kita harus mengambil berat tentang
fungsi ini untuk menjawab soalan-soalan ini ia berguna untuk mempertimbangkan kes khas di mana sekurang-kurangnya satu daripada dua matriks ketumpatan
mewakili keadaan tulen jika kedua-dua keadaan adalah tulen maka
Kesetiaan hanyalah nilai mutlak hasil darab dalam antara dua vektor Keadaan Kuantum dan dalam beberapa cara
ini adalah motivasi utama untuk Kesetiaan itu sendiri nilai mutlak hasil darab dalam antara dua vektor Keadaan Kuantum
sentiasa nombor antara sifar dan satu dan ia memberi kita cara semula jadi untuk mengukur seberapa banyak pertindihan yang ada
antara dua vektor Keadaan Kuantum dan anda boleh fikirkan tentang Kesetiaan sebagai cara yang berguna dan berkelakuan baik untuk
melanjutkan cara mengukur pertindihan ini dari keadaan Tulen kepada matriks ketumpatan jika satu keadaan adalah tulen
dan yang lain tidak semestinya tulen maka sekali lagi kita ada ungkapan mudah untuk Kesetiaan yang boleh menjadi cukup
berguna dan ungkapan itu ditunjukkan di sini Kesetiaan mempunyai banyak sifat menarik
dan itulah salah satu sebab orang menggunakannya ia mempunyai takrifan yang tidak benar-benar
bagus tapi ia fungsi yang sangat berguna walau bagaimanapun dan ia kerap sangat mudah untuk digunakan sebahagiannya kerana sifat-sifatnya yang banyak
yang menakjubkan jadi jom kita lihat beberapa daripadanya mulai dengan pemerhatian bahawa Kesetiaan antara dua matriks ketumpatan
sentiasa nombor antara 0 dan satu ia sifar jika dan hanya jika keadaan-keadaan
adalah ortogonal yang bermaksud imej-imejnya adalah subruang ortogonal atau secara setara bahawa hasil darab dua matriks adalah
sifar dan Kesetiaan adalah satu jika dan hanya jika dua matriks ketumpatan adalah sama setiap kes lain adalah di antara
tapi secara intuitif semakin hampir Kesetiaan kepada satu semakin serupa keadaan-keadaan itu atau secara alternatif
semakin banyak pertindihan antara keduanya Kesetiaan juga simetri saya sebut itu beberapa saat lalu ia
cukup jelas dari ungkapan yang kita lihat untuk Kesetiaan dalam sebutan Norma surih tapi ia perkara penting untuk diakui
walau bagaimanapun seterusnya Kesetiaan adalah multiplikatif untuk keadaan hasil yang bermaksud Kesetiaan antara dua
keadaan hasil sentiasa sama dengan hasil darab kesetiaan antara keadaan-keadaan individu
ini adalah sifat yang sangat berguna jika kita ada mana-mana dua matriks ketumpatan yang bersaiz sama
berserta sebarang saluran yang mengambil matriks ketumpatan ini sebagai input Kesetiaan hanya boleh menjadi lebih besar apabila saluran itu
digunakan kepada kedua-dua keadaan jadi dalam erti kata lain dari segi Kesetiaan saluran hanya boleh membuat keadaan-keadaan
lebih serupa antara satu sama lain ia tidak boleh menjadikannya kurang serupa dan akhirnya untuk senarai ini pun
ada hubungan yang cukup rapat antara Kesetiaan dan jarak surih antara keadaan yang ditakrifkan
sebagai setengah Norma surih perbezaan antara dua matriks ketumpatan jarak surih antara dua
keadaan berhubungan kuat dengan seberapa baik kita boleh bezakan antara keduanya yang kita bincangkan dalam pelajaran sebelumnya dalam konteks
diskriminasi keadaan dan teorem Helstrom-Holevo sementara Kesetiaan mengukur seberapa banyak pertindihan dua keadaan
jadi walaupun ia bukan perkara yang sama tepat tidak mengejutkan bahawa ada hubungan antara dua
kuantiti ini tapi dalam mana-mana kes ketaksamaan ini yang biasanya dipanggil ketaksamaan Fuchs-van de Graaf menjadikan
hubungan ini tepat secara matematik dan agak penting bahawa tidak ada kebergantungan sama sekali di sini pada saiz sistem yang kita bicarakan
kita boleh lihat hubungan ini sedikit lebih jelas dengan bantuan rajah jika kita ada dua keadaan dan kita
letakkan jarak surih antara keduanya pada paksi-x dan Kesetiaan pada paksi-y maka garis menegak dan
mendatar yang sepadan mesti bersilang di suatu tempat dalam rantau kelabu ini rantau paling menarik
plot ngomong-ngomong sekurang-kurangnya secara praktis ialah penjuru kiri atas rantau kelabu khususnya apabila
jarak surih sangat kecil Kesetiaan mesti sangat hampir kepada satu dan begitu juga
sebaliknya ketaksamaan ini digunakan sangat kerap dan sebahagian sebabnya ialah kita kerap lebih mengambil berat tentang
jarak surih akhirnya kerana ia mempunyai tafsiran semula jadi yang berkait dengan diskriminasi Keadaan Kuantum
tapi Kesetiaan mempunyai begitu banyak sifat yang menakjubkan sehingga ia umumnya lebih mudah untuk digunakan dan selagi kita berada di penjuru kiri atas
rantau kelabu yang mana kita sering dapati diri kita kita tidak kehilangan terlalu banyak dengan menukar antara Kesetiaan dan jarak surih jadi
itulah beberapa sifat Kesetiaan ada banyak lagi tapi ia permulaan yang baik dan mudah-mudahan senarai itu
membantu untuk mula membangunkan beberapa intuisi tentang Kesetiaan ini adalah contoh bagus tentang bagaimana kita
boleh kaitkan Kesetiaan dengan pengukuran tidak-memusnah ia adalah fakta yang sangat berguna yang dikenali sebagai Lema Pengukuran Lembut
katakan kita ada sistem x keadaan X yang diwakili oleh matriks ketumpatan rho dan pengukuran ke atas sistem X
diterangkan oleh koleksi matriks semi-definitif positif katakan salah satu hasil pengukuran sangat mungkin untuk
muncul jika kita jalankan pengukuran ke atas keadaan rho demi kesederhanaan katakan
hasil yang sangat mungkin itu adalah hasil sifar dan khususnya katakan hasil ini muncul dengan
kebarangkalian lebih besar daripada 1 tolak epsilon untuk sesetengah nilai kecil epsilon yang kita tidak perlu nyatakan sebenarnya epsilon
hanyalah sesetengah nombor nyata positif yang kecil sekarang kita telah menerangkan pengukuran kita seolah-olah ia adalah pengukuran memusnah
tapi kita memang tahu dari pelajaran sebelumnya bahawa kita boleh laksanakan pengukuran ini dengan cara tidak-memusnah dan khususnya kita boleh buat ia seperti
yang kita lihat dalam perbincangan kita tentang teorem Naimark dan ia berfungsi seperti ini setiap hasil a muncul dengan
kebarangkalian sama dengan surih PA darab rho dan dengan syarat mendapat hasil itu keadaan X berubah dalam
WEBVTT
khususnya dalam kes kita mendapat hasil sifar yang mungkin keadaan menjadi punca kuasa dua p 0 darab rho darab punca kuasa dua p 0
semuanya dinormalisasikan supaya kita mendapat matriks ketumpatan dan apa yang dikatakan Lema Pengukuran Lembut ialah dalam peristiwa ini
iaitu kita memang mendapat hasil pengukuran yang mungkin keadaan yang kita peroleh tidak akan berubah banyak dari
yang asal dan khususnya Kesetiaan dikuasaduakan semestinya lebih besar daripada 1 tolak
epsilon dan ini bagus kerana ia sepenuhnya umum kita tidak menyatakan apa-apa pun tentang pengukuran atau
keadaan kecuali bahawa salah satu hasil sangat mungkin jadi Lema boleh digunakan dalam
banyak tetapan berbeza di mana kita ingin sahkan sesuatu tentang Keadaan Kuantum tanpa mengganggunya sangat banyak jadi jom kita lihat bagaimana kita boleh buktikan
ini dan sebahagian besarnya ia sebenarnya perkara pengiraan Kesetiaan antara keadaan pra dan selepas pengukuran yang cukup mudah
kita boleh buat ini dengan menggunakan takrifan asal dan biasanya itu mungkin meninggalkan kita dengan formula yang kucar-kacir tapi
dalam kes ini kita bernasib baik kerana perkara di dalam punca kuasa dua luar sebenarnya kuasa dua matriks yang
kebetulan semi-definitif positif yang menjadikan pengiraan punca kuasa dua remeh kita kini boleh gunakan sifat kitaran
surih berserta kelinearan surih untuk memudahkan ungkapan kita seperti yang ditunjukkan di skrin perhatikan ngomong-ngomong bahawa ini adalah
semua kesamaan jadi kita tidak telah menghampirkan apa-apa pada ketika ini kita benar-benar hanya memudahkan tapi sekarang kita memerlukan
ketaksamaan kerana kita ingin singkirkan punca kuasa dua dalam pengangka dan kita memang boleh buat itu jika kita sanggup berpuas hati dengan batas bawah dan jika
anda berminat dengan butiran bahagian ini anda boleh dapatkan ketaksamaan itu dengan cukup mudah dengan mempertimbangkan penguraian spektral p
0 nilai-nilai eigen p 0 mesti antara 0 dan satu itu sentiasa benar untuk matriks yang menerangkan
pengukuran dan apabila kita tahu itu ketaksamaan mengikut cukup langsung dari fakta bahawa mengambil punca kuasa dua
nombor antara 0 dan satu hanya boleh menjadikannya lebih besar cara lain untuk menyatakannya ialah mengkuasaduakan nombor antara sifar dan
satu hanya boleh menjadikannya lebih kecil kita kini boleh memudahkan sedikit lagi dan kita mendapat punca kuasa dua
surih p 0 darab rho akhirnya mengkuasaduakan kedua-dua pihak dan
memasukkan batas kebarangkalian kita memberi kita apa yang kita mahu jadi formula untuk Kesetiaan
bukan formula yang paling bagus atau paling mudah digunakan di dunia tapi di sini ia sebenarnya berfungsi dengan cukup
bagus untuk mengakhiri pelajaran kita akan lihat teorem Uhlmann yang merupakan fakta asas tentang Kesetiaan yang
menghubungkannya dengan konsep penulenan apa yang dikatakan teorem dalam istilah mudah ialah Kesetiaan antara mana-mana dua
Keadaan Kuantum sama dengan hasil darab dalam maksimum dalam nilai mutlak antara dua penulenan
keadaan-keadaan itu dengan sedikit lebih terperinci katakan rho dan sigma adalah matriks ketumpatan untuk sesetengah sistem X dan katakan Y adalah
sistem yang mempunyai sekurang-kurangnya sebanyak keadaan klasik seperti X dan oleh itu kita dijamin bahawa kedua-dua keadaan ini mempunyai penulenan yang merupakan
vektor Keadaan Kuantum XY kita kemudian boleh nyatakan implikasi teorem dalam bentuk persamaan
yang ditunjukkan di skrin Kesetiaan antara rho dan sigma sama dengan nilai mutlak maksimum hasil darab dalam
antara fi dan psi yang merentangi semua fi dan s yang menulenkan rho dan sigma
masing-masing jadi jom kita kemas ini dan bekerja dengan pernyataan matematik tepat ke hadapan apa yang akan kita buat sekarang ialah untuk buktikan
teorem tapi pertama berbaloi untuk ambil sedikit masa untuk menghargai bahawa ia menawarkan kita cara pemikiran yang cukup intuitif tentang
Kesetiaan ia juga kebetulan cukup berguna dengan sendirinya misalnya untuk buktikan perkara yang lebih menarik lagi tentang
Kesetiaan untuk membuktikannya kita akan mulakan dengan penguraian spektral matriks ketumpatan kita
tidak ada kejutan di sana apabila kita ada penguraian spektral mudah untuk hasilkan
dua penulenan khusus bagi keadaan-keadaan ini tapi di sini kita sebenarnya akan gunakan
helah perhatikan bahawa dalam kedua-dua kes kita tidak mempunyai vektor asas piawai sebagai faktor tensor kedua seperti yang kita buat lebih awal dalam
pelajaran tapi sebaliknya kita mempunyai vektor yang sama seperti dalam faktor tensor pertama kecuali ia mempunyai palang di atasnya dan
itu bermaksud konjugat kompleks mengikut entri vektor-vektor ini jadi dalam erti kata lain kita pada dasarnya hanya mengambil
salinan kedua vektor-vektor eigen tapi kita ambil konjugat kompleks setiap entri dan kita akan lihat kenapa kita buat itu dalam beberapa
saat tapi ia sama sekali tidak jelas bahawa kita patut buat ini dan itulah sebabnya kita panggil ia
helah dalam mana-mana kes ini adalah penulenan rho dan sigma masing-masing dan itu benar berdasarkan
fakta bahawa vektor-vektor eigen kita adalah ortonormal dan oleh itu begitu juga konjugat kompleks mengikut entri mereka dan sekarang kita boleh gunakan
kesetaraan unitari bagi penulenan yang mengatakan bahawa setiap penulenan dua keadaan kita boleh diperoleh dengan
menggunakan operasi unitari kepada sistem yang disisih untuk pilihan penulenan khusus yang
baru kita buat operasi unitari tidak perlu sama untuk dua penulenan
tentunya jadi di sini kita menggunakan huruf U untuk yang pertama dan huruf V untuk yang kedua
jadi intinya ialah setiap penulenan dua keadaan kita boleh ditulis seperti yang ada di skrin untuk
sesetengah pilihan operasi unitari u dan v dan sekarang kita boleh ambil ungkapan
dari teorem dan mudahkan jika kita masukkan ungkapan kita untuk fi dan s dan mudahkan sedikit kita
mendapat ungkapan yang ditunjukkan di sini di skrin kini ada beberapa langkah di sana dan saya tidak tunjukkan butirannya
jadi anda tahu apa yang perlu dilakukan jika anda mahu lakukan itu tapi biar saya sebut bahawa sebab kita memilih penulenan seperti yang kita buat
adalah untuk membolehkan hasil darab dalam ini memudah dengan tepat dengan cara ini dan khususnya kita letak konjugat kompleks
di sana supaya kita dapat dengan berkesan membalikkan hasil darab dalam dalam faktor tensor kedua untuk mendapatkan bentuk khusus
yang ada di sini kita hampir selesai sekarang kita boleh gunakan sifat kitaran surih berserta
penguraian spektral yang kita mulakan dengannya untuk mendapat ungkapan ini dan pada ketika ini kita boleh
gunakan salah satu cara alternatif untuk nyatakan Kesetiaan menggunakan norma surih dan kita
selesai tentunya ada butiran di sana yang saya lompat dengan cepat dan ia adalah jenis bukti yang
anda memang perlu lalui sendiri untuk benar-benar faham tapi mudah-mudahan ini memberi anda idea asas
dan seperti biasa anda boleh jumpa lebih banyak butiran dalam kandungan bertulis untuk pelajaran yang ada pautan dalam huraian video
dan itulah akhir pelajaran yang telah berkaitan dengan penulenan Kesetiaan dan hubungan antara keduanya dan ia juga
WEBVTT
akhir unit yang telah berkaitan dengan formulasi umum maklumat Kuantum saya harap anda akan ikut saya untuk
unit keempat dan terakhir siri yang berkaitan dengan pembetulan ralat kuantum terima kasih kerana menonton